um well one of your goals now is to get
therapy taught to school kids like while
they're in school and I think you got
this all the way to the White House the
White House stepped into this yet right
yes how did how did because I remember
you talking Kenny and the thing you were
like I really want to do this I don't
know how to implement and I think it's
cool because you did Implement something
you wanted to do hopefully that is just
the beginning
um I think for me I learned so much in
the process and there's this behavior
therapy called dialectical behavior
therapy and I think it's you know it
sounds boring but it is
um it is a program that helps you
understand your emotions and wise mind
and all these different things that
you're kind of walking through and I
just figured when you're young and
you're in school they they say are you
happy face today are you sad face and I
feel like they should just keep that
going into others to other grades yeah
and I just feel like it's it's a
necessity just like physical activity is
and everything else it would be I think
it would be amazing if I could make it
happen yeah
wood no I will say this is wood I
knocked for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]